hi frank geary here come on down to
geary's and get a [ __ ] [ __ ]
custom present
and uh so we go and she's looking around
finds something quickly so i'm like cool
man thinking about the podcast in the
back of my head 5 p.m
and i'm like oh we'll be out of here
it's like now at this point it's like
one
and she says
so they have to wrap it do you want to
wait
or do you want to get something to eat
and then come back
i know what
i know what the answer is to make things
run smoothly but you have to take into
account of
who i am
like can things run smoothly
well look happy wife happy happy life
right
that's what you would argue we'll make
it run smoothly let her be happy but
then
we've got to
take we've got to take
we've got to take into consideration my
condition though
right
like we've got to take in in we've got
to take in consideration
my condition though right because if we
if we don't then my condition gets all
out of whack and then what happens
though then it's not running smoothly
because my condition is activated
because i'm bad
so i swallow and i go you know what ha
i don't even ask how long it's gonna
take to wrap it because i don't even
wanna
i don't want to push any buttons here
and and i am hungry
and why am i hungry
why am i hungry because i didn't set an
alarm because i didn't need to because i
wasn't the first person to go to bed and
i also didn't set an alarm because i
thought i'd wake up because we'd wake up
in a timely manner because we just have
to go somewhere near beverly hills but
we didn't though we had to go to costa
mesa and who didn't know that me and why
didn't i know that because i'm the
person person who put stuff in the
google calendars no she is so then wait
a second why wasn't i told about going
to costa mesa the whole day before so i
knew what i had to do the next day
because she knows about my condition
i'm hungry because we didn't eat because
we had to rush to costa mesa and then we
got there and then had to drive back
because we don't know any good places to
eat in costa mesa and now we've got to
get a gift and wait for it to be wrapped
so we might as well get something to eat
because i gotta do it anyway
so i say let's get something neat and
she says cool
and she's super happy why because she's
a tick nothing makes
your chick happier than if you
tell her
just like this
you know what let's get lunch
dude
if you're wandering around
and you've got [ __ ] to do
and you just say to a chick
yours
you say hey
you know why don't we just get
lunch she will fall in love with you all
over again like it's a tagline to a
movie that comes out late summer
fallen this summer fall in love all over
again
rupert everett and
sarah jessica parker in
we didn't eat early enough
from the makers of you didn't tell him
what he had to do the next day early
enough
from the early enough trilogy
so
i say okay we walk out
and i walk out i look around because
i'm johnny quick bites right i'm not i'm
not the guy who sits down and wants to
order i'm the kind of guy that walks up
to a counter and says i want that one
and sits down and gets a number and then
some [ __ ] dude walks up and just
drops it off
that's my [ __ ] dude
and i go you know what this is 35
minutes in i'm gonna just tell this is
the whole podcast is gonna be this
goddamn story
because i've never done it before and
this is how it's gonna be
[Laughter]
[Music]